[Music]
hey gq i'm noah schnaff and these are my
10 essentials
[Music]
my air pods of course they're engraved
with my initials on here i use them
everywhere on set when i'm not filming i
i just throw them in and listen to music
whatever before a scene when i have to
get in the character and i have to cry
for six hours like i just listen to sad
music and it's like totally puts me in
the zone there's just some scenes and
like movies or shows that like make me
cry so i'll just like quickly re-watch a
scene from a show or movie there's a
movie i just watched called everything
everywhere all at once and the ending
just made me cry so much i actually got
that trick from millie because she
always listens to music before she has
an emotional scene they play music all
the time when we're filming when there's
no audio and no lines and we just have
to walk or do something dramatic they'll
play this like dramatic terminator music
and it just is perfect just gets you in
the zone and it makes everything so much
cooler and
so they play music a lot on set
next up we have the xbox i bring this
with me everywhere i brought it to new
mexico when we were filming for stranger
things i keep it at home i bring it to
all the other places i brought it to
alabama where i was filming before this
and it's just always with me last year
when we were filming we played a bunch
of games like mario and all this stuff
recently i've just
gotten back into fortnite which is like
a little you know people like look down
on it a little bit but i love fortnite
and i love my xbox i'm so competitive
with call of duty and stuff i will
definitely get very into it and
i've definitely thrown a few controllers
in my day but you know like the normal
amount
[Music]
we have tabasco this is very important
to me i think hot sauce in general and
ketchup is just a must for me i mean
this just looks so good i i could have
this right now it goes on
anything all foods that i like
sandwiches eggs burgers everything that
i eat always has to be drenched in hot
sauce honestly this is what gets me
through that crafty i mean it's i don't
know if they're watching this so i don't
want to like [ __ ] on their food but i
would say
it's pretty good it's okay but usually i
just kind of make my own stuff the cast
members we all just order like uber eats
and this definitely put on anything will
make it better
[Music]
so here we have my tied to go pen it
could just be me personally but i'm
always spilling stuff on myself i just
filmed a movie just recently and the
first thing that my parents told the set
was like he always spills on himself
makeshire at lunch to put a robe on him
and have a thai pen with him so you can
clean up his [ __ ] because for his men
sorry
one time i was at dinner i finished my
meal whatever it was all clean and my
family was like wow like you finally are
clean you didn't spill anything on
yourself and i got up and i turned
around and my entire back was drenched
in chocolate sauce like the whole back
and the whole chair was like sticking
and the waiter was amazed he was like
how did you do that how did you get it
on your back after that is that's when
the tide pen came in it's gotten me out
of so much trouble on set because i
don't have to face the wardrobe yelling
at me i just quickly pull this out i
clean it off and it's
gone it's magic
then we have this wallet i think it's
pretty cool it's like a blue and red
louis vuitton wallet and on the back it
says have a vaton day i don't really
know what that means but i think it's
pretty cool i have so much random stuff
in here i mean i have
a metro card that i got yesterday i have
my d credit card i have a chipotle
burrito card so i get free chipotle
anywhere and everywhere i did this ad
for chipotle i've seen like david dobrik
and these people have these cards and
they were posting about it and i was
like hey chipotle like i did an ad for
you guys like i know you do those cards
can i get one it took a while because
they like specially made it with like my
name on it it took them like months to
send it and i was like please can you
send it i just want to get free chipotle
it's always weird like when i'm checking
out at the register and they're like oh
what is this and i'm like well it's like
from chipotle like it's all free and
they're like what i just got it in
january so i haven't had it for when i
was filming but next season when we're
filming people will be lining up
obviously i have to include my phone
here my case is like disgusting it's
like falling off this is the 11 pro max
so i'm like two years behind but how
could you not
include your phone i mean my phone is
like everything and i hate to say it but
it is like my whole life is on here i
document everything i do so i use the
camera i keep in touch with my friends
i've actually been seeing some like
stranger things stuff coming up on my
instagram feed and on my tick tock and i
love like commenting on them and
interacting with some of the fans i'm so
clumsy like i drop it everywhere i
always drop it like face down and then
it's like that moment of fear like did
you finally crack it there's not really
any cracks but the back is just
on its last leg here i need to get a new
case
next up we have this blue de chanel
cologne this was actually the first
cologne i ever bought i was in the
airport with my dad because i used to
just run in his bathroom and just spray
on whatever he had but then he was like
you should have your own and so i got it
at like the airport in dubai i've
definitely like been told a bunch of
times when i was younger and stuff like
you smell horrible knowing i've
definitely met like a bunch of
celebrities at like events and award
shows and carpets and they always just
smell so good i would love for like a
celebrity like zendaya or something to
meet me and be like wow like he smelled
so good let's see
[Music]
it just smells like fresh and
and good like chanel
what chanel would smell like
tbh this is a little like product plug
this is my hazelnut spread my brand it's
like a better for you better for the
planet kind of health snacking food
brand i've replaced it nutella with this
and it's it's honestly been great it's
super healthy or it's better for you
than nutella is i wanted to launch
something and i wanted to do like shoes
or clothes and then i fell on food
because i just love food i love nutella
specifically and i just wanted to make
it healthier and better for the planet
i'm so glad that i picked a food to
launch because all the stuff i have to
do is just eating chocolate like it's so
easy for me i just spend the day eating
it for all my photo shoots all these ads
so great choice by me
next up we have my suitcase
this bad boy comes with me all over the
world let me tell you the amount of
comments that i get with this suitcase
in the airport every time i go through
security people are like oh my god it's
clear like you can see your underwear
why do you use that it's i love it i
think it's so special and like different
than any other suitcase i also
definitely think it's so important to
have like a suitcase that's a carry-on
size because you're a rookie traveler if
you check your bag i think you need to
bring a carry-on you're in the airport
you put it up you grab it you leave this
has been with me in every country every
press tour last time we went to tokyo
and philippines and asia and just like
going to that side of the world is just
so different it's so amazing to see
different parts and places in the world
i love traveling and
this is
my little baby when it comes to trap
[Music]
[Applause]
my laptop i just got this like 16 inch
big one and it's so hard to bring with
me so i think for my next laptop i'll do
the smaller one i facetime my friends on
my laptop i do my work on it it's great
for reading scripts i actually just had
to read a script today and i used it so
it's great to have it's always so
interesting to read the script and see
like what's in store for this season and
i just remember honestly being so
confused like i was like what is going
on what is this what because it's so
when you read it it's very different
than when you see it but then when we
did our table read all together all the
characters read for their parts and you
really just see it all come together and
really appreciate like the ensemble that
we have i'm gonna be very sad
to say goodbye for our final season
thanks gq and thank you guys for
watching these were my 10 essentials and
i'll see you guys next time